Hello, welcome to
the Differential
Diagnosis of
Memory Disorders.
I am Dr. Leder, and
I'm going to run
you through memory
disorders today.
So our session
objectives include
understanding how
to evaluate memory
loss and compare
dementia to delirium,
describing proper
history taking in the
setting of memory
loss. We're going
to generate a
differential diagnosis for
memory loss, review
reversible causes
of memory loss, and
then apply appropriate
treatment options
if they exist.
So throughout this
course, we're going to
have a mystery case,
and I'm going to give
you aspects of the
case as we're going,
and at the end, we'll
reveal what it is.
So Alfredo is a 53
-year-old healthy
Italian man. While
on a cruise ship, he
became drenched in
sweat. He checked the
mirror and his
pupils were pinpoint
bilaterally. He then
felt a shock like he
put his finger in
an electric socket.
Now we'll be
coming back to this
case throughout
this lecture.
So the first part of
evaluating a patient
with memory loss is
taking a good history.
the important details
include a time
course whether it's
slow or rapid did this
happen over weeks
years or months was
there any trauma
involved does the
patient have a recent
history of fever or
infection do they
have any toxic habits
are there hiv risk
factors are there
vascular risk factors
or other illnesses
delirium is disturbance
of consciousness
with reduced ability
to focus it can develop
over a short period of
time including hours
to days and it fluctuates
during the course
of the day there
is an additional
disturbance in memory
disorganization language
visual spatial ability
or perception and it's
generally reversible
this can occur in
the setting of a patient
who has dementia who
then may have an
infection on top of it.
Dementia is a gradual
course and can occur
over months to years.
It can occur with
or without confusion,
but disturbance in
the level of
consciousness is generally
not a feature. And it
is an independent risk
factor for delirium,
meaning that if a
patient has dementia
and then they develop
an infection, it
increases their risk
for developing delirium.
And as you see here
on the side, this
is a picture of one
of our former
presidents who developed
Alzheimer's dementia
while he was in office.
So some of the
irreversible causes of
dementia include
early or late onset
Alzheimer's disease,
frontotemporal dementia,
chronic traumatic
encephalopathy,
Lewy body
dementias, vascular
cognitive impairment,
cerebral amyloid
angiopathy, and
Kreutzfeldt-Jakob or
other prion diseases.
The reversible causes
of dementia include
hypothyroidism, B12
deficiencies, depression,
seizures, normal
pressure hydrocephalus,
subdural hematoma,
infection, brain tumor,
intracranial hypotension,
medications,
alcohol, or
drug dependency.
So moving on to our
mystery case again,
Alfredo began to note
changes in his memory and
attention. His sleep
was affected in that
he noticed that he had
never felt refreshed.
In terms of evaluating
the mental status,
it's important to see
the patient's level
of alertness, their
orientation, if they
know who they are,
the date, where they
are. And in terms of
language, they are
checked for whether
they can recite high and
low frequency words.
So a high frequency
word might include
naming a button or a
watch. A low-frequency
word may include a
buttonhole or the clasp
of a watch. Working
memory will look at
repeating digit span,
and that could be,
they should be able
to repeat about seven
numbers, plus or
minus two, and complex
attention, repeating
a digit span or months
in reverse order.
So the first case
is a 75-year-old man
who's had a several
-year history of memory
loss. He repeatedly
asks the same question,
has not been balancing
his checkbook for
a year, but he does
continue to feed and
dress himself. His
neurologic exam is
non-focal and labs and
imaging are normal.
This is mild cognitive
impairment. It's an
in-between state of
normal aging and dementia.
And so with mild
cognitive impairment, the
cognitive change is
more than what would be
expected for the
patient's age. There is
still independence in
the community and his
activity of daily living
skills are preserved.
With Alzheimer's
disease, 47 to 55 million
people worldwide are
affected. It's the
most common
neurodegenerative disorder.
And this here is a
photo of Dr. Alzheimer,
who in 1906 wrote his
lecture on an unusual
illness of the
cerebral cortex, which
was first described in
a 51-year-old woman.
The risk factors for
Alzheimer's disease
include age, which
is the greatest risk
factor, the presence
of one or more alleles,
which is the APOE4,
low educational
and occupational
attainment, participation
in cognitive activities
are protective.
Midlife exercise
is also protective
and can decrease
dementia likelihood.
Vascular risk
factors such as high
blood pressure,
coronary artery
disease, orthostatic
hypertension,
diabetes, and obesity all
increase risk factors.
Head trauma and stress
also increase the
possibility of
developing Alzheimer's.
The clinical presentation
cognitively include
changes in verbal
and nonverbal memory,
so the patient may
ask the same question,
misplace items. There
can be difficulty with
driving a car or managing
complex paperwork.
The MOCA, or Montreal
Cognitive Assessment,
is more sensitive
and specific than the
mini mental status
exam in detecting the
earliest stages of
cognitive impairment, and
it's a much better test
to assess patients.
So the clinical
presentation from a
psychological
standpoint can include
anxiety, depression,
depression.
There can be social
withdrawal, irritability,
hallucinations, which
would happen in a
more advanced state,
and apathy as well.
The genetics of
Alzheimer's disease
include APOE E4 gene
variant, which is the
most established
genetic risk factor
for Alzheimer's.
Then early onset
Alzheimer's has three
known Alzheimer's
mutations, the amyloid
precursor protein,
presenilin-1, and
presenilin-2, which affects
a much smaller
percentage of patients.
In terms of imaging,
neuroimaging is used to
exclude structural
causes of dementia,
including large strokes,
brain tumors, and
infectious causes. With
an MRI, you would see
progressive increased
hippocampal volume loss
over time, and an
FDG PET would reveal
glucose metabolism
that is measured with
hypometabolism in the
temporoparietal region in
Alzheimer's. And as you
can see in the visual
on the right, the MRI
on the right is much
more, you see a lot
more black spaces, which
means there's loss of
brain matter, and on
the left is a more
normal-appearing brain.
the treatment of
alzheimer's includes
acetylcholinesterase
inhibitors such as denepozil
and ribostigmine if
and they can be used
if there's no significant
bradycardia or gi
issues as there can be
gi side effects nmda
antagonists such as
memantine has also
been the mainstay of
treatment for dementia,
especially for
moderate dementia, and
non-pharmacologic
therapies include
regular sleep-wake
cycle, exercise,
and reduction of
sensory stimulation.
Anti-amyloid therapies
target amyloid
plaques to prevent
buildup, and
adicanumab was
first approved but
then abandoned in
January of 2024.
Lakanumab infusion is
given every two weeks,
and denanumab infusion
is once a month.
The adverse effects
with these newer drugs
include ARIA, which
stands for amyloid
-related imaging abnormalities,
and this includes
bleeding and swelling.
Therefore, there's
a risk-benefit ratio
in terms of whether
to start patients on
this type of therapy.
So back to the
mystery case. Over the
following months, Alfredo
developed tremors,
impotence, and
severe constipation.
There were fevers of
unclear cause. Blood
work and imaging
were all unrevealing.
In terms of the
second case,
a 70-year-old woman
with hypertension was
referred for evaluation
of memory loss.
Cognitive changes were
going on for three
years before she
presented. She was
unable to manage her
accounts at work and
lost her driving skills.
There was transient
focal neurologic
episodes that lasted
for less than 30
minutes, including
motor sensory language
or visual function.
They're known as
amyloid spells. And she
developed paresthesias
of the mouth that
were spreading to other
body parts. On MRI,
numerous micro
hemorrhages were found.
And so this is
cerebral amyloid
angiopathy. It's
a buildup of
amyloid beta
plaques and tau.
The APOE4 genotype
is a major risk
factor for cerebral
amyloid angiopathy,
and it's associated
with large and small
lobar hemorrhages,
as you could see
on the right, and
slowly progressive
decline with so
-called amyloid spells.
So vascular impairment
and dementia,
there are four
phenotypic categories.
There's subcortical
ischemic vascular
dementia, which reveals
slow processing speed,
post-****** dementia,
history of ******
with language or
memory difficulties,
multi-infarct dementia,
multiple large
cortical infarcts with
apraxia, aphasia, visual
field cuts, or neglect.
And then there's
a mixed dementia with
vascular cognitive
impairment and features
of Alzheimer's.
and this is primarily
an amnestic syndrome.
Therefore, the
patients are having
simply memory
difficulties here.
Vascular cognitive
impairment,
their guidelines,
the American Heart
Association, American
****** Association
guidelines for optimal brain
health include managing
blood pressure to
keep it under 120
over 80. The total
cholesterol should be
under 200. 100, avoiding
tobacco. Exercise
should be at least 150
minutes per week with
moderate intensity or more
than 75 minutes a
week. That's vigorous.
The body mass index
should be under
25 and there should
be a healthy diet.
Case three is a 61
-year-old healthy male
that presents with
apathy and speaking
less. Two to three
weeks later, he
becomes confused and
forgets why he walked
into a room. A week
after that, he's
unable to read words
on a computer screen
or read a clock. By
the end of the first
month, he's unable
to calculate a tip,
unable to drive
or work, and
has occasional
myoclonic jerks.
By the second month, he
speaks in short
sentences,
cannot use utensils
correctly, and requires
help to eat and dress
himself. And by the
third month, is no
longer able to be left
alone, develops right
arm dystonia, which means
that the arm tightens
up and it's difficult
to move. Visual deficits
worsened in terms
that he mistook a
large bird as being a
person. He then dies
of aspiration pneumonia
four months after the
onset of his symptoms.
And this is what's
called a prion disease.
It's conversion of a
normal prion protein,
which is PRPC, which
is the cellular form
of the protein, and
it has a helical
structure. An abnormal
form of the protein,
the PRPSC, is the
final product, and SC
stands for scrapie,
a prion disease of
sheep and goats. It
turns into a beta
-pleated sheet structure,
which is abnormal.
so there's a revised
criteria for cjd which
is krutzfeldt-yakob
disease and the core
clinical features include
a rapidly progressive
cognitive impairment
with two or more of the
following myoclonus
which are rapid jerks
in the body visual or
cellular cerebellar
disturbance pyramidal
or extrapyramidal signs,
acinetic mutism, plus
imaging and biomarkers.
Sporadic Grisfeld
-Jakob is a spongiform
encephalopathy that's
fatal within a year.
The sporadic form
is seen in 85 to 95
% of cases. It
generally occurs in a
patient's 70s.
The MRI has a
characteristic pattern
and an EEG has generalized
sharp or sharp
wave complexes.
The way that it's
diagnosed is what's called
a positive real
-time quaking-induced
conversion assay for
the misfolded prion
protein and elevated
tau that's in the CSF.
Previously, a lumbar
puncture was done and
was sent off for a 14-3
-3, and that's something
that's still
discussed, but it's no
longer considered specific
for this condition.
And it's simply a
marker that there's
neuronal death. And
that's why this is now
the new way to make
the diagnosis of CJD.
Case four is a 74-year
-old man who's brought
by his spouse. You
are pretending to
be your sister, he
exclaims. There are
significant cognitive
fluctuations. some days
are more lucid other
days are not non
-exam the patient
appears parkinsonian he
has visual hallucinations
and is confused
and to the side you
see robin williams who
actually suffered
from this condition
which is called lewy
body disease there is a
fluctuating
cognition or level of
consciousness visual
hallucinations can occur
parkinsonian motor signs
the capgrass syndrome
is when a person
believes that their
loved one is impersonating
somebody else.
There is REM sleep
behavior disorder,
syncope, postural
instability, and apathy,
anxiety, and depression
are also common.
Lewy body disease has
intracytoplasmic
neuronal inclusions.
Cortically localized
Lewy bodies
are strongly related to
cognitive impairment
and dementia.
And there is a
photo of a Lewy
body on a
pathologic slide.
And the treatment
for Lewy body
dementia is
symptomatic only.
It's important to
make sure that the
family keeps the patient
safe. They should
likely not be driving.
It's very common
for the patient to
have sensitivity to
all medications. And
it's also important
to identify
medications that could
contribute to clinical
worsening. Therefore,
you don't want
to give patients
benzodiazepines or
anticholinergic medications.
The cholinesterase
inhibitors can
treat cognitive
symptoms and could
help with some
behavioral symptoms.
Typical
antipsychotics are
contraindicated in
this group of people.
REM sleep behavior
is something that we
see in many of the
Parkinsonian syndromes,
including Lewy body
dementia. It may
occur years before
motor symptoms come
on, and in a healthy
physiologic state,
vivid mentation is
accompanied by skeletal
atonia, meaning that
when they dream, usually
muscles completely
relax, but this loss of
muscle tone does not
occur during REM sleep,
and the patients
instead act out their
dreams and they could
actually injure their bed
partners or they could
injure themselves.
So back to our
mystery case.
Two months later,
Alfredo was still having
more difficulty
sleeping. I haven't slept
in five nights, he
exclaimed. His wife
reported violent jerks
at night during sleep.
So case five is a
60-year-old former
football player
who presents with
forgetfulness, anger,
mood swings, and
headaches. Multiple
concussions
occurred while he
was playing football.
And this is a photo
of Dr. Bennett Amalo,
who discovered this
condition in the last
20 years. And this
is chronic traumatic
encephalopathy. It's a
long-term sequelae of
repetitive mild traumatic
brain injury. It
can occur with contact
sports or military
blast injuries.
It's secondary to a
progressive tauopathy.
Dementia pugilistica is
a subtype of CTE,
which is the severe end
-stage dementia that
can occur from boxing.
And the CTE
presentation includes
behavioral,
cognitive, mood
symptoms, and motor
symptomatology.
Dr. Anne McKee
actually helped to
bring this condition
to the forefront.
And she's a pathologist
in Boston. And
this book, To the
Side, League of Denial,
describes the discovery
of this condition.
so the mood and
behavioral symptoms of
chronic traumatic
encephalopathy include
depression hopelessness
explosivity
physical violence
aggression impulsivity
and suicidality excuse
me one of the worst
cases that's ever
been documented of
cte involves a former
football player,
Aaron Hernandez.
He murdered another
person and then committed
suicide himself.
On brain
pathology, it was
discovered that
he had severe CTE.
The cognitive
symptoms include
impaired attention
and concentration,
memory loss,
executive functioning
difficulties, and
dementia as the
condition progresses.
And this is a photo
of Mike Webster,
who was a
Pittsburgh Steeler.
Dr. Amalu found
CTE in his brain
initially. And by the
end of this unfortunate
patient's life,
he was living in
his car and taking
high doses of
amphetamines because
of poor attention.
In terms of the
motor symptoms,
there's dysarthria
and dysphagia. So
slurred speech,
difficulty swallowing,
slowness, tremor,
rigidity, gait
disturbance.
So these patients
can often even
look Parkinsonian.
They can develop
cerebellar damage,
develop falls.
And this is a football
player who said
that he has atrophy
throughout his whole
body and his atrophy
I will never recover
from in my hands,
my arms, and now my
left leg. and it's
possible that this
condition can also be
coexistent with ALS.
So in terms of the
mystery case, the
nights passed for
Alfredo. His eyes were
closed but he was in
some type of a trance.
There were associated
hallucinations.
Hospital personnel
believed that he had an
alcohol problem but
he denied drinking.
Case number six involves
a 65 year old man
who smells of alcohol
is brought to the
emergency room during
your overnight shift.
He's a poor historian
and is confused.
His eyes were found
to be bouncing around
and he's unable to
stand without falling.
This is a Wernicke's
encephalopathy
and it's severe
thiamine deficiency,
which is vitamin
B1 and can occur in
alcoholics or
malnourished patients.
The classic triad
includes global confusion,
aphthalmoplegia,
nystagmus, and ataxia.
The classic triad is
not always present,
so you always have
to have a high
level of suspicion
for this condition.
And you could see they're
pointing to the
mammillary bodies,
which are
affected in this.
Korsakoff's
psychosis can then
occur, which is
associated with
memory loss and
confabulation.
There are lesions in
the dorsomedial nuclei
of the thalamus, which
can cause amnesia.
and the treatment
is IV thiamine
in the emergency
room, which
has to be given
before glucose.
After several months,
Alfredo began to
develop memory loss.
He was also acting out
activities during sleep
in a mindless stupor.
Hallucinations
continued, and he
didn't know if he
was alive or dead.
Case 7 assists a 67
-year-old woman with
urinary incontinence,
gait difficulty, and
memory loss. The classic
triad is considered
wet, wobbly, and
wacky. The MRI reveals
large ventricles. The
patient has a magnetic
gait and appears
Parkinsonian. This is
called normal pressure
hydrocephalus. It's
potentially reversible,
and it literally can
look like Parkinson's
with associated memory
loss. The gait disturbance
and incontinence
can occur due to
pressure on and
distortion of descending
white matter pathways.
Cognitive symptoms
occur due to pressure
on the anterior
cortical structures.
The treatment of
this condition is
a lumbar puncture.
Generally, the
patient can be
videotaped walking before
the lumbar puncture
is performed.
30 milliliters of the
CSF is drained, and
30 minutes after
the lumbar puncture,
the patient is observed
walking again. The
patient is measured
for gait, cognition,
balance, and continence
based on specialized
scale. At that
point, it would be
determined if a
ventricular peritoneal
shunt is an appropriate
form of treatment.
Case 8 is a 51-year-old
woman who's evaluated
for years of behavioral
symptoms. She
had been a business
executive, interjected
political views,
belittled clothing or body
habitus of staff members.
She was preoccupied
with sugary drinks,
started collecting
antique statuettes that
costed up and spent
up to $15,000 with
this collection. She
then refused to drive
her children to their
games, claiming that,
quote, the teams
stink anyway. And for
father's day for her
husband she gifted partly
a she gifted a partly
used cigar which she
found on the street
so this is frontotemporal
dementia and you
could see on the
picture to the side that
this is a picture of
bruce willis a famous
american actor who
unfortunately developed
this form of dementia
specific syndromes
under the ftd umbrella
include behavioral
include the
behavioral variant
and primary
progressive aphasia.
Most cases are sporadic.
Familial phenotypes
are associated
with the MAPT gene,
GRN gene, and
the C9ORF72 gene.
Frontotemporal dementia
has several clinical
features, which
include behavioral
disinhibition, apathy
or inertia, loss of
sympathy or empathy,
perseverative,
stereotyped, or compulsive
ritualistic behavior,
and hyperorality
and dietary changes.
You can go online
and watch a 60-minute
episode about frontotemporal
dementia, which
is quite interesting
and enlightening.
The diagnosis of
frontotemporal dementia
can be made by
functional neural imaging
with flu-deoxyglucose
PET. There is
no FDA-approved
medication at this time,
and symptoms are
treated with SSRIs,
atypical antipsychotics,
and trazodone
for behavioral
discontrol and agitation.
Cholinesterase inhibitors
do not improve cognition.
So mystery case is
now revealed. This is
fatal familial insomnia.
It's a rare genetic
prion disease, which
has its onset in
the late 40s. It is
severe and progressive
insomnia over months
associated with
dysautonomia, including
tachycardia, hyperhidrosis,
and hyperpyroxia, and
motor and cognitive
symptoms occur late
in the course of
the disease. There's
approximately an 18
-month survival with
this condition. And the
story that this came
from was from this
book, the family that
couldn't sleep, and
it's a Venetian family.
It's also an interesting
read for those that
are interested.
So in terms of
review, it's important
to recognize reversible
causes of memory
loss. It's important
not to miss them.
Understand the underlying
cause of memory
loss based on the
history of the patient.
Thank you very much
for listening, and
this is the end of
this presentation.